hello and welcome to this video playing
crow moss let's go for the London aha my
transposed to a gruenfelder I don't
believe much if black places g6 stuff I
don't believe much in white not playing
see form so we actually have transports
to a full-scale gruenfelder g6 setups
are pretty okay against GG 65 setters
are pretty okay against the London it's
um a case where um white not playing see
form just gives black very very easy
equality um okay he took on c4 hmm I
don't know don't think I've seen this
this kind of move order here so um I can
take on c4 I can play Queen moves
between a four for example maybe yeah
well just maybe I'll just take this I
mean rook that the rook is developed
it's nice for him but anything what I
the other moves by white is also are
also just miss placing stuff so maybe
this is the most natural way to play
okay let's just develop
you
I'd still not so obvious how he gets the
pawn back but hmm yeah this one possibly
night h5 is interesting so he might take
this before it's not possible wonder if
nite nite moves are interesting I also
wonder about night 84 as as weird as it
looks let's go for this I don't see how
he gets a get this material back
and the issue is not so much that that
I'm a pawn up the issue is that and he
has a hard time to develop with the
night on g7 so what now maybeee for man
it's got 95 then he's got 94 okay I'll
just tried to get everything into the
plane efore was a little bit was
irritating but he fought for white he's
got 94 and man maybe I still should have
done that 94
hmm
whoa he does not prevent that and now he
for their specialty 6i he's not going to
play that he wants to play a five this
is this idea he wants to play at five
okay
yeah I'll just I'll just prevent it and
it's really difficult for him to
activate now the bishop on g7 looks
terrible I think you should have played
you for earlier yeah it's absolutely not
clear what what is continuation is
Knight f6 is what I'm expecting the
question is then rookie one or rookie 11
moving the night to d2 I think I'll
playing the night not sure in general it
wants to move that night night to Air
Force possibly on it's it's not a big
issue
I think of course I'm not taking the
night on f4 I that was the point okay f3
preparing Bishop g5
okay now i'm taking to get the e4 square
now d24 Bishop to d5 but a very good
squares all 95 actually 496 that's also
quite attractive but I'm starting with
this could have ins or the g4 wasn't
sure oh that that's nice that's nice
that's straight LightSquared bishops
that's very helpful hamster teach again
okay a4 and not be five or 95 or 92 92 I
don't want to ever take so let's jump
right in
checking doesn't doesn't help
Knight b6 also doesn't help
unfortunately well okay cannot take on
c5 some and maybe you know b6 actually
thinking takes takes 97 I can bring the
night around just that do much so it
does it it loses time here I'm playing
this in a time when he far too slowly I
Bishop g7 huh and that isn't that great
I can go to be six then but doesn't it
doesn't really do much Oh check that's a
big Fork black resigns John there was a
pretty bad position out of the opening I
don't know that that captures unknown
unknown to me of course if Black gets
the porn back he's got not much to fear
but I didn't really see how he gets it
back night a six maybe but I can take
and this is kind of worrisome that porn
here Knight e5 was also also interesting
yeah this looks like that looks very
decent actually for black let's say it
takes takes and yeah now it's it's a bit
uncomfortable if I if I move my bishop
he's got Bishop d7 maybe or Bishop
Bishop d7 I guess asking this night what
it is doing now here black is fine if I
have to take he will definitely have
compensation here with the two bishops
Bishop d7 book said yeah this is ok for
black he probably should do something
like that five I have my doubts he's
just compromising his position a lot but
here for I believe is almost mandatory
something like this to activate stuff
and this this it's a very funny position
here with four completely unharmed nice
pieces the computer just says plus one
but this is something that I would have
had a hard time to play this is this is
really a lot worse to to give me give me
this yeah I think I did a decent enough
job of keeping and keeping my edge we
should give this is just good g-form
night comes here I just kept catching I
advantage here and here yes to do
something else not blunder stuff i was
thinking Bishop g7 and then I would have
gone I think MOOCs e four so that I have
Knight b6 engine gives this
an alternative was that bad then I don't
don't see it yeah it's nice it's not
clearly winning or anything but it's
very very clearly better yeah okay he
helped me by running into that fork of
course yeah probably he got to that goon
felt and it's not um an expert on this
opening I think I'm if you know the
gruene felt better you probably avoid
moves like if I hear this kind of thing
you have to I think play on the activity
on that Bishop okay well thanks for
watching